来吧
普通人
凌晨门创业的第3个部
第3种方法
可以说这个方法是最简单最确定
而且听话版是最高的
但是
大部分做不了
我们今天看视频的人一百分钟里面那种一个人做就不错了
不是他台南
可以这么讲
人人都能做
可是为什么
那么多人做不了呢
我之前给大家介绍过普通人
这台条件
凌晨门干钱
那么给大家分享过一个
叫做就是你在工作中
对吧
功能中干嘛呢就是你有信息怨吗
你有信息
你懂别人不懂的东西对吧
比如周末派人就很受
是吧因为你本身就搞些说的嘛对吧
或者什么投入资源
资源可以对接
你在酒店的服务院你知道谁
谁需要
谁用是谁
加结婚了你可以去做年纪
对吧或者是一会就是用你的
结婚
真的去做美数先生的美数
比如说我是老师
然后我介绍的东西
别人就愿意接受
那么第二种方式的话就是我说
在你的日常生活的消费中
你可以
赚一下比如说
刚开始我去选的时候不知道怎么选
但是我专业我可以帮你做绝策
那么我第二个还是过买的过程中
过买的过程中
我又在一个问题我又有那个问题对吧
我可以陪着你
去过买对吧或者是我帮你
监上了这个程度比如说你在国外我在国内对吧
就是可以帮你出来
第三种是用中的我买了的东西我不会说
加绝对吧
什么东西不会说你来帮我装
对吧
或者最后结束就分析
这里面都有什么机
新鲜这个什么机是什么的
今天那个商品阳哥的时候是最简单的
就是性权
重性权去开的出发
然后你可以有一下一种变形方式
比如说
你可以提供符合技术
然后你可以做产品
你可以做选品
对吧然后你可以做
场域
但或者联系做设讯
或者做支持联系
那我一个一个给大家拆计
然后我们先说最简单的
大家可以先怎么做
因为它说都从小时候开始的嘛
然后再一步一步高大怎么够大怎么做
我讲的每一个对我真是大力对用
我自己就是这么做的
大家可以对一看
首先第一种方式什么呢就是
我们可以用这种服务
举了例子就是我自己是有兴趣的比如说
我特别选猫我特别选小东
一个真正喜欢猫喜欢小东顿的人和不喜欢人是完全不一样
他天然的就喜欢
然后你就会发现因为你喜欢所以你做的
比别人要好
你发现那些那些的喜欢
你的很多细节和不认识不一样的
所以
你在生活中只要发现一个缺少你就可以
通过服务刚开始挣钱嘛就可以通过服务来这种钱
举了一个啊
比如说
结价值的时候
就很多人家里要出去玩
你不能老带个猫或者在个狗
我带个承误出去吧
在家里谁来商务呢
只是很多人的通过
但是如果你整好结价着你不出去
然后你呢
有喜欢这个小东损
怎么办呢你就可以接下
就可以在
跑一条也好在什么地方
平台上发个消息说我是身身
平时给他
照片啊你可以一点是出来
你喜欢的人小东西和别人不太一样的
然后我可以帮你照顾一天大家多少钱
因为你专注这么一天
你是怎么照顾的
你都可以有直播
你就可以拍照片给人
这个别人和你比不了
专业的那些是和你比不了的
而且他成漫都没办法和你比为什么
你是成义喜欢
对吧
那你还要喜欢什么啊
比如说我喜欢健身啊
对吧我喜欢
我老一些机器啊你像我以前的时候
就喜欢中机器
战狗
不是画了重新中心的
装了一种然后装够的感动
我就喜欢
因为那段时间就喜欢
所以就是很多人就是
他们家战脑化的都是让我妈
你至于周边的很多战脑化的
附近一块了都找我了
因为我就喜欢
对吧所以有时候有些时候也能
获得一些收拾
但这种收拾的话就是它会有时间成本
对吧但它是最好的
入口的地方
第二种方式其实也是我自己的一个
车战过程
叫什么呢就都
就是场域的连机
有一种连机尤其是获联网绿来的有多多的时候人们需要用连机的
书哥好玩类子啊就是
我不知道你们那个你们现在有没有啊
我年轻的时候
那个时候有一个
组织调绿业先钟
都是旅游什么叫旅游啊
就一帮人背着
看着你
起爬山呀
去远逐啊我那个时候就就是这样的一群人
其实
像不大家相互这样都不认识
然后通过论坛我们相互这样就认识了
认识了一会打遇运
我们去爬四姑娘嘛
对然后
然后
一块出一碗
相互时间关于的很好
然后就认识好就朋友对吧
你后来你还像我个人来说我你像我做
这种
就是
花花
我也先喜欢花花
然后就
总是这个社区这来的知道吧
数上现在的社区对吧
维体最社区
后来又开始闭巾
后来我开始话结分遇运最开始传上面对了
所以开始是面对的
后来有人越来越多
为什么我做短这一变的时候
一上来就在人呢
你说
这种说是技巧的原因不是的
声音我之前就记得了好多好多的
人这跌跌就好多人的就
他就来了
最后来的比说什么是听过个群呢
什么读书群呢
怎么就孕孕孕孕孕了啊
这就是一种人的情感的连进
这是第二来
主要在今天这个
环境里这是非常非常重要的东西
就你先做这一场活动
然后有很多自同道合的朋友
在你后面做很多事的时候是非常非常有帮助的
我就是一个典型的证明
第三个有什么呢
就是你购建一个产品
就是我在我喜欢什么
我就在网上购建
对吧
比如说你们知道那个
欢迎明白
你们知道吧
原来是个话想
然后来做那种任务合逻
就在现在做
很容易看了以后觉得特别好
就很专注
做完以后就特别喜欢
好像就开始下单
就买了好多
对对
就是我喜欢一个东西
我把我的专注
在网上你们看到
很军意味你的专注
所以很军会就会陷入你
就会觉得你
我好棒
对吧
然后他就会卖你的产品
因为很多时候过卖产品什么
就会因为陷入
而且你的东西有匹别人好
大家就会想的
所以很多人就是
如果你是个手域人
那特别好的是一件事情
就是我在网上
呈现给你们看
就好像我是一个
我不是因为意义无需求
给你展现
我就是因为我喜欢做菜
我是真的喜欢做菜
我是真的喜欢做花
我是真的喜欢做什么
做的做讨议
对吧
我就在网上
只是我做我自己的事情
对吧
你们看不看不重要
就像
这个
好多人问我
就是
我在网上做直播
也订明你们很多人都知道
我是周二晚上七点直播
但是其实我每天的时候
十点到十二点的时候
我会把
直播打开
我就认真做我的事
就真正做我的事
其实我是不看明目的
好多人在
下面看一会说
这也行吗
这也可以吃不忙
不少我
我做就不行了
对吧
我昨天休息的时候
为什么我做的时候
没人看呢
我怎么把人留住
你看咱俩的出发点完全不一样
我的出发点是什么
我就做我自己的事里
我做我自己的事儿
而已
我的目标
不是赚钱
不是把人留住
我就做我的事
也顺便让你们看着了
人们是因为我足够的
主安住才看我
不是因为我懂什么话
是我好多人都跟你搞你
你没了
所以那你做这个事情
所以可能看上了以后
他会被你的专注所感染
同时你的东西我很专业
那就会购买呀
就是产品吧
对吧
就是很多人做那个手传
对不对
这个都可以
就是你手艺人都可以走
那么还有什么
就是东西不一定是我走
但是那我就喜欢
对吧
我就我就给你们展示
你们将会那个晚上是下枪 tremendous
jetzt晚上下枪擠着
对吧
然后我掉于的
我掉于我卖于巨
是不是
这是我是因为我太喜欢了
我在那个公公中
我可以给你们展示
对的
我的印象尾气
我在手标的一节
我在余余的一节
我的什么轶的力兼
对不对
然后我的了解我的干ку
我就用一份分享
我不已经做这个东西
但是我骗你们你就骑 Cody
选拼
买什么
对不对
很多人知道他问你什么就不让那个动用
我专业我是买什么
我分享给你
对吧
你就比如说有的时候我在网上就直播的时候
我去帮你都回来的
都不关注
但是中间或者休息的时候
基本说你给我推荐那边书吧
我要是说我可以我说你想
你那么办什么
那个方向我知道我知道给你推荐
我不知道不知道对不起我不推荐
因为我专业
所以很多人就会在我这买书
我就把东西送完报的书双里
但我从来不推荐书经过看
我从来不是派
是听说你妈妈的买书没有
就是你问我我会告诉你
我知道我会告诉你
我不知道我就说对不起我不知道
因为我专业所以我是选买书
所以很联会在我这买书
你是与我把东西挂得出传上就会有什么
你跟我去写上
因为大家都知道你放上你的就是你认为
买得好的
对吧就是这一本说就不是买得好的
这一本书就好
你觉得不错
对吧这是买书的选手
然后第一
还有一种方式是什么就知这边写
这个就不用写事了
就好多人都在做这个方向
比如说我每天
不是我
还有有人每天
以前每天拍六十秒的视频
每天每天每天每天每天每天
那我们慢慢吃去搞得很大
后来还搞来吧
就好多这种知识
知识伏会的
其实很多时候人买的是知识吗其实不是
其实现在知识过期信息是过宰的
买的是一个确定性
买的是一个确定性是你把我锅锐的知识
然后你我有一种联机
然后一种认同
你看你
你做兴趣就好了
就很认为什么做不了
我跟大家讲
就很认太早急了
对吧
我只要我喜欢我做我自己喜欢做的事情
而这个是用了让我成长
如果顺便还能给别人的来价值
有人愿意支付的就更好的
那我就一直做就好了
这样的缺点是什么就是你早期是没有结果的
在早期没结果你已经啥都没干
你就在第一次干
没有结果
你可能要干涉很长一段时间
比如说六个月九个月
或者践践一年啊
我啊你开始越来越转住了
你看是越来越转越了
然而们才开始关注你
这个时候很多人是熬不过去的
熬不过去的因为很多人都没说话给
我赚钱呀
我要变信呀可能关注这个
但是你拿我来说
你明明说我拍短片
你拿我来说我拍短片包括我去直播
没人看我会不会我会不会看输
没人看我会看输
本身我也是要看输我也是要思考
我要是总结我要反思每天切点什么做的事我会去
起度的
我不过是把他拍出来以后
把那个价值放回到这裏
没有人看我的视频我仍然会看输的我仍会总结的我仍会起度的
但是我们很多直播怎么办吗
这都会正前过来了
拍了好一天
为什么不正前
这是我跟那家讲的时候
他是最简单最确定听话的最好的
对吧
然后你会发现
但是可能能够不了
所以会好好讲一讲
你到底喜欢什么
而这个是真的能够让你个人成长
下好他还能转到前注意不是你转到前别人能转到前
确实能转到前就会生用正名有人能转到前
而是能让你成长你都喜欢
那还等不上班呢
对吧
转入的认真的去做问题的是不用太关注外面的情况就是转入的认真做认真实
你过了那个时期因为认同一个是那个边界
边界点
拧阶也过了那边界开始包发起
以前的时候
他就是评论
一过了一点
开始包发
就是
不是
不要本那个去我就是要去做这个事情反正
没有结果我自己也提升
然后重新来大家就是我说不用的认怕被
展现
然后一旦过了一列
就
爆发了
吃吃看